before the break we were talking about
the Carter show her love baby shower I
recently hosted there were 100 new
momma's and moments to be in the virtual
celebration it was so awesome and we
actually have a few of them joining us
right now
Morgan Amanda Mary are you there hello
everybody how are y'all did
congratulations to all of you thank you
so exciting um okay so Morgan you just
had baby Beckham right so was it a
difficult path to bring into this world
I heard it was it was so I was told
13 years old that I had endometriosis
and I would never have children
so by the time I met my husband it was
like a deal breaker for most people that
I had dated so I told them pretty early
on the cage just so you know I can't
have kids just as casual as that too and
and he's like no problem we'll cross
that bridge when we get to it and
literally a week later is Mother's Day I
went into urgent care because I had this
migraine I couldn't get rid of a Meccano
nose pregnancy story but we were not
expecting that news at all and then
between that and six and half years
later we have had many pregnancies that
have resulted in loss through a
miscarriage and ectopic so we tried for
a really long time to bring another baby
into this world and like nothing went
right so I was like I'm gonna go ahead
and get my mom makeover and find some
other things to focus on and two months
later I couldn't I was pregnant a second
so yeah things happen when they're
supposed to right one of my friends was
actually the same thing happen to her
when she was young and they said because
of in Demetria so she wouldn't be able
to have children and she tried for years
and and finally they were able to make
it happen they she ended up having twins
and it was that's a hard thing you know
to hear if your dream is to have kids
you know and that happens to a lot of
women so thank you first of all for
being so open and vulnerable about that
story except that a lot of people
connect to that story and Amanda your
pregnancy also came as a bit of a shock
right yeah actually um I'm 37 so I
wasn't even sure if it was so possible
to get pregnant or if it was going to be
difficult but I went off birth control
in early 2019 and we kind of just
figured whatever happens have
fast forward a year and a little bit and
we found out at the end of March that
I'm pregnant so that was you know a
great news and very exciting especially
during the times of Kovac but it's made
it a little difficult to Cove it you
know again it's my first pregnancy so
I'm not really sure what to expect with
the doctors and my husband hasn't been
able to come to any of my appointments
so that's been kind of difficult
he's new I hear the heartbeat and see
the ultrasounds and all that fun stuff
so I've been trying to FaceTime with him
as much as possible but we went for our
12-week point a well I went for my
12-week appointment and I was facetiming
him and my parents and just so they
could hear the heartbeat when the
surprise you know big surprise from the
tech was oh my god it's twins we didn't
know that it was twins we weren't
planning for twins it was really
exciting to watch you know both my
parents and my husband just trying to
overcome with emotion in that moment
congratulations by the way like what a
gift and like tonight or not and then
you get two little gifts it was great
you know you pray for a miracle and you
get to say thank you for one pregnancy
so I slightly hate you know
congratulations Amanda they're really
really cool story Mary you've had an
interesting experience as well you're a
nurse and an ICU so what's it like to be
an essential worker who's pregnant
during a pregnancy is did you have
concerns obviously definitely kind of an
unnerving time to be pregnant definitely
under every time for everyone but you
know my my husband and I both he works
he's a corrections officer in a jail and
I'm in a hospital so we're both kind of
in a high-risk area so you know it just
kind of day in and day out things
changing my you know my husband and I
this is our third pregnancy first child
so you know we were kind of very scared
going into things thinking well we've
had two unsuccessful pregnancies and now
we have one and now we're kind of
dealing with this virus that nobody
knows anything about and you know I'm
working in the ICU directly with
patients who have
been exposed and have the have the virus
so it's been kind of kind of scary but
you know we have a healthy little girl
and that's three or three weeks away
from our due date so it's very exciting
and you know things have been good and
she's been healthy this whole process so
it's it's exciting I'm glad to be near
the finish line Oh
oh my gosh the finish line is so
beautiful it's like Oh finally I love
you get out get out get out that's
that's really great hey and thank you so
much first of all from all of us for
what you do especially during this time
putting your life on the line not only
yours but your little babies like that's
that's it's above and beyond to ask
someone to do that so thank you so much
from all of us to just you all the
essential workers out there that's
really really thank you gracious of you
I already got to have an enormous
virtual baby shower before
Huggies gifted you a gear of diapers at
the Carter shower and they hope you'll
fall in love with the Huggies special
delivery diapers and wipes which are the
perfect pair for your perfect hair but
they want to do more so they're starting
a $5,000 college fund for the baby of
whomever wins the game we're about to
play are you ready yeah everybody can
use money towards college it is so
expensive all right let's play baby boom
or bust
okay so this is simple I'm gonna ask you
questions all about babies you each have
cards and pins right there in front of
you right you ready okay and when I ask
the question
you write your answer down then we'll
see who gets it right you get it right
you get a point let's do this all right
all right first question what's the
first sense a baby develops okay are we
all ready okay show me okay no one wins
this one cuz you're all wrong the answer
is actually touch um I didn't know that
as well so we're all failures together
okay so let's it's only a failure if you
don't keep trying let's keep trying okay
here we go
which celebrity named their baby stormy
all right ladies so let's see you the
key answers you came up with let's see
here let's see what you wrote oh my god
okay I didn't know that at all and all
of you got that right Kylie Jenner is
the answer way to go you all get points
okay I'm the loser err okay so well
here's the next one what percentage of
women actually give birth on their due
date so here's the thing this is hard
that's like a 1 out of 100 so I'm just
gonna say whoever gets the closest to
you know the percentage of women
actually give birth on their due date
whoever gets the closest gets the point
are you all cool with that okay okay
here we go let's show me your answer
oh you got the answer I have no idea no
okay I cannot even believe you right now
there he who got that right five percent
all right so we have we have another one
babies are born without which body part
write down your answers I think I
actually did know this one because I
thought it was weird okay y'all ready
okay everybody show certain types of
bones kneecap kneecaps for the win oh my
gosh it's a three-way tie well it seems
like all we can do here folks is just
give you all $5,000 where you go babies
for collars up I love that everyone wins
that was so cool all of you ended up
getting that that's courtesy of Huggies
thank you so much Huggies that money is
gonna go to good use and again
congratulations not only on the five
grand y'all but just on your little ones
these are your miracle stories to you
know happening so that's it's a
beautiful thing to hear that hope and I
know a lot of moms out there who
struggle getting pregnant and and
everything coming to fruition that's a
hard hard thing to deal with emotionally
and physically mentally so thank you for
being open thank you for being
vulnerable with your stories and
congratulations and I just can't wait
for y'all to all I know beckham's boring
but the others aren't so I can't wait
beyond the smell and smell them they're
so cute
alright y'all have a good one stay safe
and healthy alright thank you
alright bye ladies alright it's time for
a break we'll be right back with what
I'm liking
[Music]
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my Channel please don't
make me keep going